assume you've been asked to write down 3
x 3 remember you haven't been asked to
calculate it so you pick up your pen and
write it as 3 times 3
here we are multiplying 3 by itself just
once now let's say you've been asked to
write down 3 x 3 x 3 you write it down
as 3 times 3 times 3 in this example we
are multiplying 3 by itself twice 3
multiplied by itself multiplied by
itself
now you've been asked to write down 3 x
3 x 3 and so on 7 times
so now you're kind of bored but you
don't have a choice so you write 3 times
3 times 3 times 3 and so on
7 times yes I know what you're thinking
the more number of times you multiply a
number by itself the more tedious it
gets for you to write it down so that
brings us to the question is there an
easier way to denote these kind of
operations what kind of operations am i
talking about here the ones in which a
number is multiplied by itself many
number of times the answer to that
question is yes we do which brings us to
the topic of exponents 3 multiplied by 3
can be written as 3 with a 2 in the
superscript this is read as 3 raised to
2 how do we get a 2 it depends on the
number of threes you can see so we have
2 3 0 and hence we write it as 3 raised
to 2 in the second case we can see three
threes hence it can be written as 3
raised to 3 how do we get a 3 in the
superscript that's because we have three
threes and in the final example we have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 threes so we write this
long string of numbers of seven threes
as 3 raised to 7 if we have any number
say
a multiplied by itself many times we
write it as a multiplied by a multiplied
by a multiplied by a and so on if there
are n number of A's in this product then
it can be written as a raised to n the
number of a is called the base and the
number n is called the exponent in the
three examples we saw all of them have a
base equal to three
it is just the exponent that varies in
the first case the exponent was two in
the second case the exponent was three
and in the final example the exponent
was seven in the coming videos we will
look at the different properties of
exponents